All right, this --
this is gonna take
some serious thought
and contemplation.
I might have to
stand up.
For reals?
You can stand up
if you want, sure.
Can I? Is it legal?
[ Chuckles ]
I want to keep it
in justice.
We can't possibly decide
about this
Chippendales/Chips Ahoy! thing.
I almost drowned
in there.
[ Both laugh ]
It's got --
It's got too much.
Can you swim?
[ Laughing ] It's got
too much water in it.
[ Coughing ] Yes.
What do people call you
for short,
or do they use
your whole first name?
Jess. Call me Jess.
Jess?
Yeah.
I didn't know.
Keep it chill.
Call me Jess.
But I like your name,
too, though.
Call me J.
You can just make it
a noise.
J?
Just like, fhht!
J brings it back
to the whole weed thing.
Yeah, right?
But I also do like calling
you pbht!
[ Chuckles ]
Fhht!
[ Both laugh ]
Wouldn't it be great --
Not in chambers!
[ Laughs ]
Respect my chambers!
I don't know --
Do you want some cookies?
Yeah, like this little --
this ramekin.
Very cute.
I like it, too.
It's adorable.
Oh, shit.
Chippendales?
More like Chips Ahoy!
[ Laughs ]
Isn't that the joke?
That's the joke.
It's so bad.
But I think
both of those guys
sell that joke
on a nightly basis.
I want to know
what his closer was.
Was like a Dorito bit?
[ Both laugh ]
Was it like
a Frito-Lay closer?
Doritos? More like
full of shit-o's!
[ Laughs ]
I used to be Peppermint Patty.
But now I'm Peppermint Fatty.
[ Laughing ] You're
all out of sync, man.
You got it
all switched up, man.
This guy's dad
was coming up with
a million of them
every day.
Wait a minute.
$1,000?
Like, I've got jokes, and I
think a lot of them are funny,
but I don't know if I can
put a price point
on one of my shitty jokes
at a G!
That's what I'm saying.
If your friends
and you say something funny
and one comedian says,
"Hey, can I have that?"
You either go, "Sure."
[ Both laugh ]
Or "50 bucks. 50 bucks."